hey everyone it's my photos from order
flows calm and welcome to my order
fellas market analysis for Wednesday
January 17 2018 now next week I believe
on Thursday the 25th I will be doing a
presentation with ninja trader talking
about order flow now I know some of you
guys may not be aware of it yet but
ninja trader is actually going to be
releasing a or some order for an order
flow quote sweep unquote I haven't seen
it yet you know they had an announcement
they're gonna probably trying to roll it
out later this month but you know you
know with ninja trader sometimes ninja
trader has their own you know their own
form at a time where you know they say
this date but it's actually three months
four months later but anyway I'm curious
to see what it looks like now again you
know people that are familiar with my
order flows trader understand that it's
not just a volume footprint chart it
also has four additional order flow
tools to help you as a trader find price
support find price rejection in the
order flow find when traders are stuck I
don't like to use the word trap traders
but find one you know basically you have
blow-off moves either up or down and you
know the last buyer has bought nor the
last seller has bought and you know a
few other little little things that I
don't want to get into right now but if
I jump in a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or making you
the type of investment decision futures
train contain substantial risk is not
for every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading only those were sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
four it's not necessarily indicative of
future results one reason why I always
say that disclaimer first because you
know I want people to realize that
results are not typical you know people
will have different results they do vary
you know it depends on you and what
you're going to do as a trader you know
your decision making process and not
everybody is you know has the same
thought process and can pick things up
as easily as other people you know I
know some people order flows is just
just becomes like the perfect complement
to how
trading and for others you know order
flow takes a while to learn so you know
I don't know where you fall into that
but you know hopefully you can pick up
some little nuggets I like to drop
little gold nuggets as I call them you
know in these presentations so the tools
they use in this presentation is the
order flows trader which is a volume
footprint chart but it's not just the
plain volume footprint chart you know
like even for example sierracharts has a
volume footprint chart but you got to
know how to analyze it you know you got
to know what to look for it just says
any chart or you could have any form of
charting tool but if you don't know what
to look for in the chart what's what's
the point of looking at it just like
with the dome right everyone thinks oh
I'm gonna get it I'm gonna get a dome
I'm gonna get this dome or that dome you
know the depth of market tool and I'm
gonna be successful but the problem is
they don't know what to look for in the
market they just think oh I'm just gonna
sit from the dome and stare at it and
it's gonna come to me it may it may not
chances are it's it's not you know I
mean it's again I hate to talk about
psychology but it sort of comes down to
the right-brain left-brain
you know where or some people are able
to visualize things and understand it
from a picture much better than
analyzing numbers or text and the other
tools I'm gonna talk about in this
presentation is the vault owes snr
levels which is support and resistance
levels based on order flow now the the
software runs on ninjatrader runs on
ninjatrader seven and ninjatrader eight
you know people that have been watching
my videos know that for the last couple
of years there i've been a big proponent
of ninja trader seven especially when
this past year when ninja trader eight
has been out but i've made the switch
i've cut the cord and i don't really run
into seven on you know i are used nt7
for testing things but you know the
dominant one that i use now is is anti 8
then the charts are used in this
presentation are NT eight charts so that
said let's let's take a look
talk about emini first this morning and
what i wanted to talk about is this
buying imbalance here so i've tried to
make it bigger so you can see the the
chart easier and on the 11:23 you had
the stack buying imbalance here okay so
this market had been trading you know
back and forth so
it's uh you know I don't know called
10:30 okay we've basically been trading
between 27:91 you know 2794 then here at
11:23 we start breaking out of this
ranges so to back it up here look at
this okay sort of been in this range you
know between you know you can draw the
lines here to make it a little easier to
see or my horizontal line you know
between this this high area in this low
area call it here's from you know this
is 10 20 down to 10 30 back up there
back down here shrine to it sf6 but
sometimes I press the wrong button
because I think I'm looking at it and I
press the wrong button but anyways it's
these two so we're training here back
and forth I think you start breaking out
here boom you come back you come out
come back in boom look at this because
trading above it close above it in this
bar it's open this up so you can read to
put print close above you're not coming
back in like here you're closed above
but the next bar right back in here you
close above this bar is gonna be telling
what are we gonna do are we gonna close
above this this area that we have been
trading sideways for the last hour or
we're gonna come back in and what do you
get you get this nice stacked buying in
balance four levels deep one two three
four so you know you got aggressive
buyers there's very little counter
selling here you get fifty nine twenty
fifteen then it starts going to some
strong two-way trade here you can see
two thousand five thousand two thousand
two thousand four thousand four thousand
it's it's finding a new value area some
new RSA value area rather finding a new
area above this recent zone congestion
area I hate the only use the term zone
or congestion that you have just been
trading and so now you've got supportive
buying coming in so here you got the
aggressive buying right as you're
breaking out of this congestion area
stacked imbalances is the giveaway then
you come in here and you've got you know
very very strong two-way action both on
the bid side and
and on the offer side okay so who's
gonna win now that clue is this stacked
imbalance what do we do we trade back in
here we're still above this point of
control all right this point of control
here guys as I've often said many times
you know when you're making a move up
watch your point of controls point of
controls are going to be your resistance
level so here you got side by side point
controls then next bar up we're above
the point of control next bar up above
that point of control the next bar up or
above that point of control then we just
sort of go sideways here then you get
stats selling in balance e that's not a
good sign okay well let's you know it's
not the end of the world oh god stacks
on a balance others you know mortgage
the house and get short no you wait you
know if you got short here say you got
short off the stack stone about say you
said well we just had this nice little
run up now I got stacks on the balance I
gotta get short okay but if you got
short here you gotta cover it here what
do you got you got a stack buying the
balance again um
I'm not saying you know you got a spy
and sell every single stack buying a
balance of stacks selling a balance you
know take things in context of the
market it's a little easier to take this
one because you're just been in a
congestion area and you're breaking out
of that now you're sort of you know you
know it's not the first time you hit the
high then you got the stack sound about
see how I stack sound imbalances as
you're going sideways and then what
happens it comes right back immediately
the next minute with a stack buying
balance and another stack buying
imbalance so you know this is bullish
here this one is bearish to neutral
stack buying and balanced followed by
another stack buying and balance with a
bullish ratio here you have a bullish
ratio here but I always loved these
bullish ratios when you get them after a
stacked imbalance you know going in the
direction so here you have a stacked
buying a balance in a bullish ratio
that's usually a very strong signal and
then watch point of control this bar
okay again you know I had been saying if
you expect the market to rally watch the
point of control so you got pouring a
control point of control point until all
higher and when you're doing it's
holding as your support if this is going
to be your high your swing high this
point of control should hold as
resistance it doesn't it comes right
here it comes up test that high and and
honestly you know this when I was
looking at this high earlier I thought
you know maybe we can sell off because
we had a high less volume
can't I miss tactic balance maybe we can
sell hop I thought but this bar here
this bar gave it away that we're not
going to sell off so you know it's
perfectly legitimate to take this short
right here but you got to manage your
trade you know people always you know
one of the questions have been working
on this thing about training psychology
but you know people I said well you know
if I got some if I understood the
psychology or you know the psychological
side of trading I'll be much more
proficient at trading but it's it's not
just the psychology you know it's not
like you could pick up a book on
psychology and you can become a great
trader no you still have to have a
method of training that's that works
that gives you an edge over other people
in the market I mean if you don't have
that you know you can't trade period but
rather what the psychology of a trade
trading does is put you in the right
mental state all right to make those
decisions you know to to not be like
okay well you know I've got this
double-double hi here and up top here
less volume stacks on the bounce I get
short then you're gonna sit here and
stay with the trade as it starts going
against you know you know if you
understood yourself as a trader and you
know have the right mindset I I find
mindset is the better term than
understanding trading in psychology as a
trader you have to have the right
mindset to know that to trade the reason
for being in the trade is now over and
there's bullish reasons to be here
rather than still you know being short
as you're sitting up here thinking well
you know waiting for it to come back and
sell off no no you you had your chance
right
and it's been invalidated by the order
flow as it's developing that's why you
use order flow is to read what the
market is telling you unless you read
what the market is telling you but read
what the market is presenting to you you
know the market is telling you hey you
know we had a bearish sign here but it's
come right back with some very bullish
signs in the market and what happens
boom you start rallying again as I said
earlier support and resistance can often
be found in the next bar based on the
previous bars porn and control so here's
porn control rallied went up that's that
high so now your pony control is down
here
you have a port of control here in this
green bar right if there's going to be
support should hold was it do trades
there gets one point through okay now
watch point of control of this bar
okay are we going up or down next bar
point of control is up here where does
this bar trades right down to that point
of control trades down there again here
I'm here you just got three point
controls all lined up together and then
BOOM you can make the the further move
up but you know the whole reason for
being in this trade initially was it was
right here okay so you make that high up
here then you just start going sideways
again you getting some point of controls
lined up again before the market shoots
up again now you know that's simple
now the other one I want to talk about
is uh I said I'll say that simple hooked
um the other I mean to me that was that
was a that was a clear one the other one
I want to talk about was bonds what they
were my own
next up on my days here this one here
this is the bonds this morning about
6:00 in the morning it might be a little
bit hard to see there on the size but I
really want to talk about is just the
point of controls here I just make it a
little bit bigger in the volume in
reading the order flow okay so you know
people always say oh you know why should
I buy the order flows trader as opposed
to another order flow software like I
said ninja trader is supposed to be
launching some form of volume footprint
sharp this year the end of this month I
don't know a hum but it's on the website
it sort of buried in their announcements
but again you know if you don't know
what to look for if you don't understand
how to read order flow then you know you
might as well what's the point just
gonna burn money like said you know a
lot of times people think that oh yeah
oh my get a volume footprint charting
it's gonna make it trading easier no you
also need how to know how to use it okay
you could have a scalpel right but if
you're not trained on how to use a
scalpel to operate you know any yeah I
could use a scalpel cut myself as
opposed to a doctor cut my you know cut
me open with the scalpel I'm sure his
cuts gonna be a lot neater than the cut
I give myself
you know because I'm not trained on how
to use a scalpel or as a doctor I'd like
to believe is more trained than than I
am but anyway I'll have to talk about is
this low here at 6:30 and you have look
at this volume here racial bounds low
racial bounds little pointed controls
right on the bottom very bullish sign
you know if you know nothing about order
flow you know if you take away one
golden nugget from this this video today
watch those green bars with porn
controls on the bottom you know those
are very bullish if you have a red bar
with corner control on the top it's also
bearish let me see if there's one here
you know there's one yesterday here
there's a bearish one these these you
know this is the ball toss SNR levels
here's porn resistance now again I'm
going to sort of segue into it now it's
what the SNR levels do is it reads the
bars freeze the order flow to tell the
determine if there's porter resistance
in an area so you can see here we're
rallying up and boom the SNR levels is
giving you a zone now you can adjust how
how far out you want this zone you know
I've got a set at five I mean I like
five you know for me I don't like so
many things cluttering up my chart I
like to be able to look at it but if you
were to extend it out you know this is
where it gets a little bit more telling
you I'll set it to 15 here just to make
a little bit easier I will show you
visually what I want to show you give it
a second here okay boom so it's telling
me you know in this area there's there's
resistance so don't be surprised to see
it come right back up that area and then
sell off because you're coming up to an
area where there's resistance in the
market okay so what does so how do you
do that what do you do right in as a
trader well what you do is you sit up
here okay you know I know I got the zone
up here where this market should be
running into resistance and if we come
back up here we should sell off so what
you do in this area the reason why it
draws out this area is because that's
where you place your limit orders right
in this case sell limit orders for the
pullback up in here now that you could
be aggressive and just trade it and you
know at this point it's just right
before the I say right before the closes
you know 1:48 p.m. Chicago time market
closes like a 4 but cash closes in the
bonds at 2 p.m. is is it will cash close
so when am I talking about the markets
about to close its you know that the 2
p.m. cash close but anyway you have this
area up in here alright where you know
you should be running into resistance I
mean we can retest it I mean as a
resistance level expect it to be
retested and you do so you have orders
it's just sitting in here right this is
about talking about having taking trades
with tight stops is you have your limit
orders to sell up in here you know
between 150 101 150 100 to 150 103 so
you're not filled at O 3 your stops just
right up here at O 4 so imagine you're
selling o twos you just stop at o4 o
ones with your stop at o4 then what
happens you know you sell it imagine you
sell here 151 even down here 151 even
okay the previous high 151 even stops at
O for risking three sticks there was it
do 151 even all the way down this is now
you're into the evening session here
because this is actually on the reopen
after the session closed here then we
reopened and traded higher hit that
level hit that support resistance level
151 boom right down a 150 16 that's a
half a half a full point there in the
bonds at 16 ticks then you come down
here we're on midnight you got a you got
a support level okay it doesn't test it
immediately comes down in here later and
test it look at this level test it this
is at around midnight okay
around midnight you come back down in
here if you you put your buy orders in
here you know this is 150 14 150 13 150
12 where's your stop it's just right
here like 150 11 or I think it's 10 10
or 11 boom it comes back down into that
zone you get filled was it do it rallies
back up almost up to 151 even but it
rallies from you know 150 13
150 14 all the way up to 150 28 then
here you got a cell this one fails okay
honestly it just fails you have your
cells in here it pulls back
it stops you out period I mean I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna argue that it didn't
stop you out there that that's a trade
that work guy sorry that's just a trade
that didn't work but okay but you just
had to trade that worked a nice six you
know 15 16 picks another you know
hopefully at least eight ticks maybe 10
ticks here I mean maybe you could have
caught something out upon this move you
know there's two different ways to trade
it I want there's the aggressive way
which is you just get long right after
you know you get the signal and the
second way what the tighter stop is you
wait for that pullback and okay so you
know the other thing that I want to talk
about is you know when you're dealing
with support and resistance
you know failed resistance becomes
support okay or failed support becomes
resistance so here you've got resistance
that fails was this become support I
mean it sort of trades in there and then
makes a new high now it comes back down
right this was supposed to be your
support level right comes down blows
back through now this is the way I like
to look at these so what I do is I don't
sit here try to buy it again rather what
I do is I wait for the market to come
down through it and then trade back up
towards it now I'm looking for it as a
resistance again and it comes back in
there again you know that that's not
something I advocate for a lot of
traders I because you know that's sort
of my own way of trading you know failed
support comes resistance resistance
becomes support once they fail but again
you know it's something for you to think
about it's it's more of an advanced
concept of support and resistance but
yeah I don't like using this as a level
you know in here you know it doesn't
work here doesn't work or so this is
your support level now you know here's a
support level that broke down and then
use it as resistance a bit later again
you know for some people you can but for
most I I really wouldn't consider it
because
really what I'd be looking at as you're
coming down here I see price rejection
in the ratio in the ratio then you come
back up in here so I know I you know I
had this resistance area potentially
earlier and as we come back up in here
as I see reason
you know price rejection before the
market sells off going down down down
down now the last one I'll talk about is
the buns with the support and resistance
levels this is yesterday I mean it
doesn't really get any more
picture-perfect than this honestly I
mean look at this so this is the open
and then rallies up
you got a cell cells off by rallies
cells off this by didn't work out this
first one but then boom you got a nice
little rally up here the cell yeah it
comes off a little bit comes back up
here again this is an area you know
around you know 150 90 you know call it
maybe this whole area look at all these
pies in here outside these cells so you
know you're sort of coming up into this
area of resistance you know these buys
here's a little bit more spread out
still you mean I would expect it to come
back down it at this point here I would
be looking for this market to come back
down around the 84 area and probably
rally back up into the 90s and it does
then it sells off down here but I mean
look so I say you get short off this
trade here you know 92 or whatever this
is that none in this area boom it trades
down into the 70s and you gotta buy it
trains back up into the 90s you know you
could almost I mean look at this okay
there and I don't know this one sort of
an outlier you know because you got to
lower here I mean if you call it here
you know this is your your range you
know you look at that you're just
trading back and forth back and forth
back and forth even here what are you
rally back up from this buy would you
rather you rally back up into this area
where you have sells boom boom boom
then you sell off again to we're down
here I mean if you you know we're to
extend these outs again you know I'm not
a big fan of extending them out too long
I mean you can it's up to you instead of
10 devices if I set it to longer
I don't want to set it too long but I'll
call it 50 I just want to show you this
is a minute based chart so from four
sent it out a little bit longer here cuz
I really just want to highlight to you
you know how train around the levels
again personally I think you can look at
them visually a you don't need to just
necessarily draw them out so far on your
chart but look at these levels here okay
even if you were to draw this level out
all the way out to here you know the fat
levels holy not here you got a level
here where's the trade right down to
here
here again I didn't I wasn't able to
draw it out but if you were to extend it
out you can do it visually or is it
trade back up to here you know even here
this one what do you trade back down to
here you know then when you trade you
trade back into this level here this
level here
so you can see hopefully you should be
able to see the the importance of
trading with support and resistance
levels I said yeah today in the buns was
it was really a picture-perfect day
textbook day but it was a nice day but
honestly you know yeah that's what it
looks like and even go back to the
previous days on this isn't day before
look at this okay boom you got the
support level you trade back down in
here and you shoot up again here you got
the resistance that well did poke
through I'm it held even here you got
the support level you know draw this out
you know it comes out to here here
that's where you trade back in 270 all
the way back up to 90 no buns our our
terrific market to trade you know here
you got a cell here you got a nice buy
and you buying it from what is that 160
55 or is it do trades trades up the 70
almost comes off again down the 60
before trading back up to 80 you know
that's that's 30 ticks you know here you
got this buy pulls back here right into
that area look at this
whoops I mean you can pull these down
this is just to give you the visual here
right this is your support area right
again what do you do you pull back in
here is we call this what 70 71 72 all
the way up to 90 above 90 95 that's
another 20 ticks right there I mean
that's I know you know it's again I
sound like I'm preaching to the choir
but you know you just get these trades
like that all day long you know every
day in in the markets you know whether
it's buns
whether it's bonds whether it's euro
currency
you know everything so you know I'm
gonna keep this video going on too long
20 25 minutes but to learn more about
order flow you can strive to subscribe
to this YouTube channel or visit my
website order flow is calm I'm gonna try
and get more I'm not trying to write
more you know I mean writing is sort of
a forgotten art I've gotten more into
posting videos than actually writing
down commentary but you know I mean
there's people that you know like to see
it in writing rather than watch a video
for 25 minutes so you know thanks
everyone and have a great day bye bye